today we're talking about mergers and
acquisitions a new cloud region data
privacy and sustainability i'm max
altenstall and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
it's exciting when your company has just
acquired or merged with another
organization the beginning of an
important new chapter in its history and
it's critical though not as exciting to
properly manage the combination of your
cloud accounts fortunately we've got you
covered in this blog post we look at how
to approach mergers and acquisitions
from the perspective of google cloud
these are the best practices that your
google cloud technical account managers
follow or that we recommend you follow
if you plan to perform the integration
yourself
we are excited to celebrate the opening
of our new google cloud region in milan
in partnership with tim you can now
store data and leverage fast reliable
and secure cloud services to build and
deliver highly available low latency
applications for your customers all on
the cleanest cloud in the industry
the new milan region europe west 8 is
now part of our global network of 34
regions and 103 zones bringing google
cloud services to users in over 200
countries and territories worldwide it
is the first of two regions that are
opening in italy the second will launch
in turin in the coming months
google is announcing our intention to
offer new contractual privacy
commitments for service data that align
with the commitments we offer for
customer data once these new commitments
become generally available we will
process service data as a processor
under customers instructions with the
exception of limited processing that we
will continue to undertake as a
controller
we will provide further details as we
implement these updates plan for google
workspace google workspace for education
and google cloud services beginning in
2023 and in successive phases through
2024. to learn more about our approach
and other upcoming changes check out our
privacy resource center
don't miss our first ever google cloud
sustainability summit on june 28 2022
learn how business and technology
leaders are building for the future and
get insights to help you enact
sustainable change within your
organization
at this digital event you'll have a
chance to explore the latest tools and
best practices that can help you solve
your most complex challenges
and you'll be among the first to find
out about our product updates across
google cloud earth engine and google
workspace
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud